Venons de lire les versets 11 à 18 de la lettre de Paul au Galate.
Je vous rappelle, c'est l'une des lettres les plus importantes,
les plus pertinentes de toute l'histoire de l'humanité.
C'est la lettre qui était l'une des premières de l'apôtre Paul
et qui va faire ce travail de manière très efficace
de ne pas permettre que le christianisme soit compris
comme une espèce de ramification du judaïsme.
Donc le judaïsme a été, selon les descendants du vent,
un moyen à travers lequel la compréhension du vrai évangile
arriverait à son accomplissement, à sa plénitude.
Et donc l'évangile a été prêché à Adam et Ève juste après la chute,
avant qu'Israël ne soit.
Et ça, c'est vraiment le travail de Paul en Galate.
Pour convaincre que cette communauté qui a été implantée par l'apôtre Paul,
les Galates, l'église des Galates,
arrive à une compréhension tellement affermie
de son identité en tant qu'enfant de Dieu, en tant que chrétien,
et qu'elle ne se sente pas diminuée par l'influence de ces hommes
infiltrés à cette église qui voulaient suggérer,
car ils étaient ethniquement juifs,
qu'ils étaient plus importants que les Galates.
Et donc, dans les Nouveaux Testaments,
nous avons Galates et Romains,
qui sont les lettres par excellence
qui nous font comprendre
que c'était plutôt temporairement et temporellement
qu'Israël était à service
de la compréhension du vrai évangile,
qu'il est de considérer
que le christianisme était une espèce de ramification
qui pourrait être sous contrôle
ou sous la domination politique d'Israël.
Ça, c'était très important pour l'apôtre Paul,
et cela a été aussi très important
pendant la réforme protestante.
S'il y a un autre épisode dans l'histoire
où l'église était les plus vulnérables
à la manipulation ou la domination
un peu judaïsante,
c'était notamment au 15e, 16e siècle
quand l'église catholique est arrivée
au comble de sa corruption
et qui cherchait à suggérer,
comme les Juifs,
que certaines traditions humaines,
certains efforts humains,
humains pour accomplir la loi,
pourraient assurer les saluts.
Et donc, les saluts n'ont lieu
qu'exclusivement à travers Jésus-Christ,
notre représentant,
car lui seul a accompli parfaitement
la loi des dieux à notre place
et a souffert à la croix
la punition qu'on méritait.
Et donc, c'est par la foi seule.
Galate était considérée par Luther
comme sa Catherine.
C'était le nom de son épouse.
Il voulait dire,
c'est Galate qui m'a, quelque part,
émancipée de cette domination catholique
qui, même après avoir eu la conviction
que Christ est suffisant pour me sauver,
mais donne l'impression
que même après la conversion,
je dois conspirer religieusement,
payer des pénitences,
afin de maintenir ou réconquérir
l'amour ou la faveur des dieux.
Et donc, même si le christianisme
nous déclare clairement
qui est tous ceux qui sont convertis,
ils ont été adoptés dans la famille des dieux,
ils deviennent des vrais chrétiens,
des vrais enfants des dieux en Jésus-Christ,
la relation dans la pratique,
dans ces cercles religieux,
cette relation vers Dieu devient névrotique.
On a plutôt la sensation
que Dieu est un tyran,
nous sommes ses esclaves,
et notre relation avec Dieu
pour qu'on puisse recevoir sa faveur
ou conquérir son amour
dépend de nos performances ritualistes
ou religieuses.
Donc, c'est la transpiration
pour se sentir aimé des dieux.
Et donc, Paul,
il va souffrir de dures peines
dans cette lettre
pour corriger cette mauvaise influence
des judaïsants
pour défendre
que la justification
lorsqu'elle a lieu,
donc c'est un terme biblique
très important,
justification lorsqu'elle a vraiment lieu
dans le cœur de quelqu'un,
cette personne,
elle est non seulement
déclarée juste
d'une fois pour toutes
devant les tribunaux de Dieu,
comme elle est transformée
dès son antérieur,
sa nature est appelée
nouvelle nature,
et donc elle n'est pas
tout simplement
adoptée en termes légaux
devant Dieu,
elle est transformée
en tant qu'enfant de Dieu.
Donc, il y a deux aspects
quand on parle des justifications,
c'est la grande thèse des Galates,
il y a un aspect légal,
donc on se dit
devant les tribunaux de Dieu,
moi, j'embrasse Christ
comme mon représentant légal,
c'est-à-dire,
il a vécu la vie parfaite
à ma place,
il a souffert ce que j'ai mérité.
Et donc,
toute ma dette envers Dieu
est acquitté,
je peux accéder à sa présence
sur la base des mérites
d'un autre.
Par contre,
la raison d'être
de cet évangile,
lorsqu'il a dessiné
cette manière
de nous déclarer juste,
c'était notamment
pour qu'on puisse avoir
accès à lui
et pour qu'on soit
tellement réconcilié
avec lui,
pour qu'on soit
comme lui.
Et donc,
l'intérêt
de déclarer juste
quelqu'un,
de la part de Dieu,
c'était notamment
de restaurer
son image
en nous.
C'était de restaurer
notre filiation.
Donc,
l'adoption,
elle est sécurisée
car elle est fondée
légalement
sur les mérites
du Christ.
Par contre,
cette adoption
n'est pas qu'il est légale.
Donc,
ceux qui Christ
a justifiés
légalement,
ce sont ceux
qui l'ont transformé
en tant qu'enfant
de Dieu
par cette union
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
une union légale
avec Christ
par la foi,
mais c'est une union
vitale.
Voilà pourquoi
Christ,
il va nous enseigner
que non seulement
on est pardonné
sur la base
de ses mérites,
mais nous sommes
transformés
car il est la vigne
et nous étions
des branches morts
qui ont été greffées
en Jésus
qui est la vie
et donc sa ville
va écouler
ou découler
envers nous
et nous allons
manifester la vie.
Donc,
la sanctification,
si vous voulez,
est une partie
inséparable
de la vraie
justification légale
car Christ
ne nous a pas
tout simplement
par l'évangile
affranchis
de la condamnation
de l'enfer
mais il nous a
affranchis
de la domination
ou la pollution
de péchés.
Et donc,
ayant résumé
les points
les plus importants
de la lettre,
nous arrivons
à cette conclusion.
Une église
qui aurait dû
mieux savoir
car elle était
implantée quand même
par l'apôtre Paul,
les grands apôtres Paul,
mais qui était
très vulnérable.
Et donc,
si une église
qui était
implantée par l'apôtre Paul
était si vulnérable
aux judaïsants,
combien nous
dans nos jours
encore aujourd'hui
sous ces mauvaises influences
des judaïsants,
des ceux
qui sont en train
de vouloir
présenter
une espèce
d'évangile
qui soit
domesticable,
contrôlable,
diluable,
si vous voulez,
adapter l'évangile
au goût du client,
faire que l'évangile
devienne
politiquement correct.
Et donc,
Paul,
il arrive
à la fin de la lettre
en disant
« Il y a
des imposteurs
infiltrés
entre vous,
ils vont jouer
de manière
très subtile
et ils vont vouloir
vous tromper.
Et peut-être
que certains d'entre vous
seraient
partiellement
trompés.
Par contre,
même si partiellement
nous sommes des victimes,
on n'est jamais
complètement innocent.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul,
il est en train
de parler
du danger
des imposteurs,
des judaïsants,
mais il est en train
de diriger
cette lettre
au peuple.
Il est en train
de responsabiliser
la communauté.
faites attention
à ces imposteurs,
apprenez bien
à leur identifier
entre vous.
Et là,
Paul va lancer
une espèce
d'ultimatum.
Il va exhorter
cette église.
Il va dire
« On ne se moque
pas des dieux.
Vous avez
toutes les informations
que vous devriez avoir
à partir de là.
C'est à vous
de préserver
vos âmes,
cette église.
Car c'est
qui l'homme
aura s'aimé,
il va certainement
moissonner. »
Et donc,
cette église
était infiltrée
par des chrétiens
nominaux
qui avaient
toute l'apparence
externe
d'être chrétiens,
qui avaient appris
à se porter
comme les chrétiens
et qui pourraient
même professer
ce qui est essentiel
par rapport
à la foi chrétienne.
C'est Jésus
qui sauve.
Par contre,
la manière légaliste
dont il vivait
régnait
l'authenticité
de l'évangile.
Et nous allons comprendre
en fait qu'à la fin
des comptes,
ces hommes voulaient
l'évangile
sans son escandale.
Christ
sans la croix.
Ils voulaient
adapter
l'évangile
au goût
du client,
des non-régénérés,
au goût
de la présence
d'influences
plus puissantes
dans la société.
car Israël
et les Juifs,
ils avaient quand même
une importante influence
dans la société,
dans la politique.
Et donc,
Paul arrive
à la conclusion
en disant,
c'est presque
comme s'il était
en train de dire cela,
maintenant,
la préservation
de cette Église,
l'authenticité
de cette Église
va dépendre
quelque part
de votre attitude
envers ces hommes
qui sont au milieu
de vous.
C'est comme si Paul
avait suspendu
la communion
avec l'Église
des Galates
et que cette Église,
elle était
sous discipline
jusqu'à ce qu'elle
change
des procédures.
Donc,
verset 11
de l'apôtre Paul dit,
« Voyez avec
quelles grandes lettres
je vous ai écrites
de ma propre menthe. »
Donc,
par là,
nous voyons de manière
très claire
que l'intention
de l'apôtre Paul,
c'était de s'écouer
cette Église
en écrivant
personnellement
des grandes lettres,
comme s'il était
en train de sortir
du poupitre
et s'écouer
les personnes.
Et donc,
par cette lettre
qui était une prédication
en forme de lettres,
il est en train
de sommer
cette Église
à une réaction
rapide.
Il va donc poursuivre
avec ces versets
qu'on a lus
avec une caractéristique
très différente
de ce qu'on va trouver
dans la majorité
de ces lettres.
Car même
certaines Églises
qui avaient
des grosses erreurs
ne reçoivent pas
un traitement
si dur
que les Galates.
Car à la fin
de presque
toutes les lettres,
l'apôtre Paul
va partager
un désir,
par exemple,
de faire des projets
missionnaires ensemble,
il va exprimer
son amour
pour certains membres,
il va nommer
certaines personnes,
mais à la fin
de la lettre des Galates,
on n'a pas de salutation
ni générale
ni personnelle,
on n'a pas d'action
des grâces
pour cette Église.
Donc,
la communion
est apparemment
suspendue
et conditionnée
à la réparation.
vous avez bien
commencé,
mais maintenant,
vous êtes au bord
de régner
complètement
l'Évangile.
Et ce qui est
le plus intéressant,
c'est que l'insistance
de l'apôtre Paul
dans toute la lettre
est une insistance
à défendre
leur vraie
liberté chrétienne.
Donc,
la lettre
la plus préoccupée
à la réjouissance
pleine
de la filiation
divine
en Jésus seul
est,
en même temps,
une aile
marquée
par un zèle
qui cherche
la vraie correction,
qui,
par amour,
va confronter.
Et donc,
là,
on parle qui
des éléments
qui composent
cette conclusion,
mais le contenu
de cette conclusion,
il est
davantage
effrayant.
car quand on lit
certaines déclarations
comme
et maintenant,
pardon,
comme
les versets
16,
paix et miséricorde
sur tous ceux
qui suivront
cette règle
et sur tout
l'Israël des dieux
et que personne
désormais
n'aimait face
de la peine.
Voyez comment
il conclut la lettre ?
Car je porte
sur mon corps
les marques
de Jésus.
Et donc,
on voit
de manière
très claire
que Paul,
il est quelque part
à la limite
avec cette église.
Et donc,
quelles sont les ailes
de Paul ?
Qu'est-ce qui justifie
ces ailes ?
C'est notamment
les versets 12,
14,
12 et 14
qui montrent
en fait
les cœurs
de cette passion,
de ces ailes
de la peau de Paul ?
Et donc,
à la fin des comptes,
ces enjeux
parlent
du vrai évangile.
Cette communauté,
elle est mixte,
elle est partagée
entre ceux
qui sont vraiment
convertis
et ceux
qui n'étaient
jamais convertis
même s'ils se disent
chrétiens.
Tous ceux
qui veulent
se rendre agréable
dans la chair
ou selon la chair,
c'est-à-dire
au-dedans de l'église,
il y a certains
qui veulent se mêler
avec la religion chrétienne,
chose que je n'ai
jamais compris,
afin de se rendre
agréable
selon la chair,
d'avoir une réputation
comme moraliste,
comme si
la foi
était une couche
à être ajoutée.
Donc,
moi,
j'ai par exemple
mon degré,
ma profession,
ma carrière,
ma famille
et ma religion.
Donc,
Christ n'est pas
radical.
Tout n'est pas
en train
d'orbiter
autour du Christ.
C'est comme
si on avait
une couche
de vernis
dans la vie
qu'on appelerait
la religion.
Pourquoi ?
Car c'est possible
d'adopter
même une religion
comme une manière
de se rendre
plus agréable
selon la chair.
Vous comprenez ?
Et Paul
va faire un contraste.
Pour ce qui me concerne,
loin de moi
de me glorifier
à aucune autre chose
qu'en Jésus-Christ
ou à la croix
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Donc,
ce qui va
déterminer
de manière radicale
ce qui est un chrétien
et ce qui n'est pas un chrétien,
c'est si tout orbite
autour du Christ
ou si on est
au contrôle
de toutes nos vies,
y compris la religion.
Si nous voulons
nous rendre
à la chair,
selon la chair.
Et donc,
Paul va dire
loin de moi
la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autres choses
qui est dans la croix
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
par qui
les mondes
est crucifié
pour moi
comme je le suis
pour les mondes.
Car ce n'est rien
que d'être
circoncis
hors circoncis,
c'est qu'il y a quelque chose,
c'est d'être
nouvelle créature.
Donc,
qu'est-ce qui va diviser
à la fin des comptes
l'Église ?
C'est certains
d'entre nous
dans l'Église visible,
on a traversé
ce qu'on appelle
la nouvelle naissance,
la régénération,
nouvelle création,
nouvelle nature.
et d'autres
d'entre nous
sont plutôt
dans les efforts
de donner
l'apparence
d'être converti,
circoncis
ou en circoncis,
c'est qu'on peut voir
tout simplement
à l'extérieur.
Et la motivation
finale
qui est
le signe
de cette conversion,
c'est si
notre gloire,
notre tout
est Christ,
notre plus grand plaisir,
ou si ce sont
les plaisirs
que ce monde
peut offrir.
Et qu'on considère
que même la religion
peut-être compter
entre les plaisirs
de ce monde.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc,
ce que l'apôtre Paul
veut faire
pour conclure l'être,
c'est de présenter
les deux grands archétypes.
D'un côté,
lui-même,
en tant qu'un ministre
authentique
et en tant qu'apôtre,
mais en réalité,
en tant qu'apôtre
ou pasteur,
il n'est rien de plus
qu'un vrai chrétien,
une personne convertie.
Donc,
il doit être
les modèles,
les repères,
la référence.
Mais à la fin des comptes,
on a
chez un apôtre
authentique
ce qui est
les vrais convertis.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et de l'autre côté,
il est en train
de donner des pistes
de comment identifier
l'imposteur
entre nous.
Et là,
dans les cas
des Galates,
ce sont les judaïsants.
OK ?
Et donc,
il est en train
de responsabiliser
l'Église
par une grande
exhortation,
par un grand
ultimatum
et nous devrions
nous laisser porter
par ces mêmes
poids d'exhortation
en voulant
nous évaluer
à la lumière
de ces deux
paramètres.
La vérité centrale,
c'est que
les tests
ultimes
de la réalité
de la nouvelle création
sont une vie
qui se glorifie
exclusivement
dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
À la fin des comptes,
la vraie liberté,
le vrai pardon,
la vraie conversion,
c'est de me demander
où se trouve
enraciner mon identité.
Où je peux
me glorifier.
Soit je me glorifie
dans mon humiliation
affichée à la croix
et mon élévation
en Jésus-Christ
et c'est tout
et c'est plus
qu'il suffisant
et c'est glorieux
pour moi.
Où je suis
en train
encore
de compter
toutes les étoiles
que j'ai pu raconter
pendant ma vie.
Comme Paul,
juste avant sa conversion,
hébreu d'hébreu,
donc éthiquement
israélite,
une étoile filante,
étudiée
avec Gamaliel,
une carrière
appréciable
à tous les niveaux,
dégrés,
etc.
Et Paul,
à la fin,
va dire
j'ai tout considéré
comme de la boue.
comparativement
à la connaissance
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
pour amour
de qui j'ai perdu
toute chose.
Mon désir,
c'est de me conformer
à sa souffrance
afin d'être retrouvé,
ressuscité avec lui.
Donc,
les tests ultimes
de la réalité
de la vraie conversion,
de la nouvelle création,
de la vraie filiation
des dieux,
c'est est-ce
qu'on s'est glorifié
exclusivement
dans la croix
de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ ?
Et la question clé
qu'on a soulevée
à partir de ces textes,
c'est
quelles sont les preuves
d'une vie
qui s'est glorifiée
exclusivement
en Jésus-Christ
par opposition
à l'hypocrisie religieuse,
une menace
à nous tous ?
Donc,
on a déjà considéré
quelques réponses,
nous allons considérer
encore d'autres
aujourd'hui.
Donc,
la première réponse
qu'on a considérée
au verset 11,
c'est qu'une vie
qui s'est glorifiée
réellement dans la croix,
manifeste une affection
authentique pour Christ,
son évangile
et pour son peuple
plutôt
qu'en faux
soins
intéressés.
Donc,
l'apôtre Paul,
il est,
attention,
au milieu
de ses voyages missionnaires,
il n'est pas dans un séminaire
ou il n'est pas
dans un bureau
pastoral
en train d'écrire
cette lettre.
Il aurait pu l'être.
Il est en train
de souffrir,
il est en train
d'être persécuté.
et les nouvelles
du danger
de cette église
arrivent
et il s'arrête
pour écrire
cette lettre.
Et en écrivant
cette lettre,
nous voyons
que ses caractéristiques
de l'apôtre Paul,
qu'il était brillant
dans sa connaissance
de la suture
romaine,
grecque,
pour écrire
les lettres,
mais on voit aussi
qu'il n'est pas
si préoccupé
que ça
avec la rhétorique,
avec la suture,
avec la forme.
Et il va laisser
à plusieurs reprises
que ses affections
se manifestent
inévitablement
quand il est en train
de traiter
certains points.
Et donc,
voyez avec
quelles grandes lettres
je vous écris
de ma proprement,
c'est car même
avec les silos,
il veut aller
au-delà
de la formalité
afin que les personnes
comprennent
les poids
de ces exhortations,
pour que les personnes
puissent voir
de manière palpable
que cette lettre
qu'elle était
écrite
avec de l'encre,
mais aussi
avec des larmes,
aussi avec du sang,
aussi avec
de la transpiration.
Et il veut
que toute la communauté
sache
quand elle est en train
de lire cette lettre
quels sont les niveaux
d'affection
que l'apôtre Paul
a pour Christ,
pour son évangile
et pour son peuple.
Donc,
la personne
qui devrait lire
cette lettre
pour la communauté
ne pouvait pas
lire cette lettre
de manière apathique.
tout comme aujourd'hui,
on ne peut pas
considérer
qu'on a entendu
des beaux sermons
si on ne voit pas
des vraies affections.
Des sermons apathiques,
ce ne sont pas
des sermons,
ce sont des lectures,
ce sont des essais.
car prédication
par nature
selon les paramètres
du Nouveau Testament,
c'est de devenir
bouche des dieux,
c'est de partager
les mêmes affections
des dieux.
Et nos affections
doivent être
proportionnelles
aux enjeux
et aux sujets
que nous sommes
en train de traiter.
Un prédicateur
ne peut jamais
se sentir
au contrôle
de ses sermons
complètement
ou de ses affections.
apôtre Paul,
voyez avec
quelle grande lettre.
Et on a vu aussi,
je vous encourage
à revenir
sur cette prédication,
les fausses
affections religieuses.
Car les fausses
affections religieuses
peuvent être
dissimulées.
Et donc,
c'est très important
de considérer
en fait
quels sont
les éléments
qui nous permettent
d'identifier
l'authenticité
des affections religieuses.
ni apathiques,
ni l'émotionalisme
s'il n'est pas
fondé
sur les vérités
ou sur les circonstances
réelles.
Et les vraies
affections,
elles sont toujours
spontanées
et authentiquement
connectées
aux vérités
selon leur gloire,
selon leur sévérité
et aux circonstances
qui traversent
le peuple des dieux.
On ne peut pas parler
de l'enfer.
C'est comme on disait
de Robert Murray McShane
qui ne pourrait
jamais parler
de l'enfer
sans verser
de l'âme.
Parler de la destinée
éternelle des âmes
sans affection.
Donc,
une vie
qui s'est glorifiée
réellement dans la croix
manifeste une affection
authentique pour Christ,
son évangile
et pour son peuple
et pas en faux soins
intéressés.
La deuxième vérité
qu'on a vue ensemble,
c'est qu'une vie
qui s'est glorifiée
réellement dans la croix
promeut de la liberté
par les dons des soirs
plutôt que l'autopréservation
manipulatrice.
Donc, verset 12.
Tous ceux qui veulent
se rendre agréables
selon la chair,
donc l'intérêt
de ces personnes
n'est pas
au peuple des dieux,
c'est
de devenir
agréables
selon la chair,
appréciables
selon la chair.
Et ces personnes-là
vont vous
constreindre
donc ça veut dire
une espèce
de coercion
qui n'est pas
forcément
toujours
physique
ou menaçante
au niveau physique
mais menaçante
au niveau
de la conscience.
Des personnes
qui arrivent
à se mettre
dans des positions
où ils deviennent
agréables
selon la chair
pour nous manipuler,
les risques
en fait
des positions
qu'on occupe
à l'Église.
Et la lâcheté
parfois,
la paresse
spirituelle
que nous avons
parfois,
car c'est très
intéressant pour nous,
de vivre
une foi
basée sur
des règles
que les autres
nous donnent.
Car vivre
la vraie vie
chrétienne
basée
sur un désir
sincère
d'être agréable
à Dieu
à chaque instant
peut nous placer
dans des circonstances
où ce n'est pas
très facile
de définir
ce qui est
la bonne démarche.
et donc,
ce n'est pas
noir sur les blancs.
Voilà pourquoi
les juifs
ont dû rajouter
plus de 600
lois
aux lois
bibliques
afin de rendre
la vie chrétienne
une vie
des surfaces
ou on préfère
écouter
d'une secte
qu'on ne peut pas
jouer au foot
pour ne pas s'énerver
ou qu'on ne peut pas
écouter un tel type
de musique
car la grâce
commune
n'existe plus
et tout est
complètement contaminé
ou on ne peut pas
couper les cheveux
ou on doit
toujours s'habiller
d'une telle manière.
C'est tellement
facile
de mener une vie
apparemment religieuse
par l'austérité externe
au lieu
de nous trouver
à chaque instant
devant Dieu
et nous demander
comment Dieu veut
que j'agisse
maintenant.
Si Christ
aurait suivi
toutes les lois
qui ont été ajoutées
et qui n'étaient pas
les principes publics
il ne serait pas
à la maison
des Matthieu
pour manger
avec le public
pour évangéliser
pour diminuer
leur nombre
il ne pourrait pas
accueillir
cette prostituée
qui est en train
de nettoyer
ses pieds.
Et donc
ces personnes
elles veulent
vous constreindre
afin de vous
faire circoncire
donc là
à nouveau
on devrait
participer
à la décision
à la circoncision
et ça
c'est vraiment
encore plus subtil
car les personnes
qui nous manipulent
nous donnent
la sensation aussi
que c'est nous
qui devons décider
à nous mettre
sous leur joue
sur leur manipulation
donc
souvent victimes
jamais complètement innocents
uniquement
afin de n'être pas
persécutés
pour la croix
des crues
donc l'autopréservation
donc ils vont
pénétrer
cette église
qui à leurs yeux
semble être vulnérable
on va faire
appel
au reste
de la chair
qui même
dans un chrétien
sont retrouvés
et voilà pourquoi
plusieurs d'entre nous
veulent donner
de plus en plus
l'écoute
aux légalistes
dans ces cas-là
c'était la circoncision
normalement
ces manipulateurs
ils sont monothématiques
ils peuvent prendre
quelque chose
qui pourrait être vu
comme quelque chose
d'appréciable
une diligence
plus
acharnée
à l'apparente
synthétée
l'abstinence
l'austérité
d'être diligent
par rapport
à une emphase
et élever
cette emphase
qui parfois
est légitime
à la place
des dieux lui-même
ou de l'évangile lui-même
et donc pour ces hommes-là
c'était la circoncision
uniquement
afin d'être persécutés
pour la croix du Christ
et donc là
c'est important
de nous rappeler
pour faire la transition
au prochain point
que c'est une tentation
pour tous les pasteurs
et tous les chrétiens
chercher de séparer
l'inséparable
donc je me rappelle
au moment de ma conversion
j'étais un surfeur
et je suis sorti
de l'eau
à Rio
il y avait un homme
en costume
cravate
sous un soleil
de 40 degrés
et pour moi
c'était clairement
un esclavage
et clair
sa compréhension
n'était pas
biblique
par rapport
à la réjouissance
qu'on pourrait avoir
des bonnes choses
de la vie
et je me rappelle
de m'avoir dit
à moi-même
si ça
c'est la vraie religion
je ne le veux pas
si c'est ça
vraiment
de connaître Christ
je ne le veux pas
et donc c'est clair
que certaines personnes
sont persécutées
non à cause
de la croix
du Christ
mais à cause
de leur fanatisme
de leur manque
de sagesse
par contre
c'est impossible
de séparer
l'évangile
de l'escandale
de la croix
donc certaines personnes
dans nos jours
sont en train
de nous dire
ok
on ne veut pas
créer des obstacles
extra
pour l'évangile
mais il veut
nous encourager
tellement
à présenter
l'évangile
par une sophistication
apologétique telle
ou contextualisation telle
que c'est comme si
l'évangile
n'avait pas
de confrontation
comme si l'évangile
n'avait pas
de croix
sauf que
les points de départ
de l'évangile
c'est notre crucifixion
à nous
car c'est la représentation
de ceux qui ont mérité
recevoir
de la part des dieux
c'est l'humiliation
complète
de l'être humain
il n'y a rien
en moi à protéger
en moi à promouvoir
car ce qui crie
c'est en train
de souffrir la croix
c'est que moi
je mériterais
souffrir
pendant toute l'éternité
à l'enfer
c'est ma misère
spirituelle
mais imaginez-vous
combien d'argent
ne sera pas perdu
dans ce système
juif
à cette époque-là
si tous les systèmes
des pèlerinages
les fêtes religieuses
tous les systèmes
des positions
des escripts
des pharisiens
toutes leurs écoles
ne pourraient plus fonctionner
car Christ est déjà venu
et tout est accompli
et ce système
a eu son objectif
accompli
et rendu obsolète
plus de temples
!
plus de sacrifices
les messies
a véritablement été crucifié
folie pour les grecs
comment un seigneur
un roi des rois
peut être si faible
à point d'être attrapé
par la multitude
et finir
dans la pire façon
d'être exécuté
et de l'autre côté
scandale
pour les juifs
comment les sangs
des dieux
Dieu lui-même sur terre
loin des dieux
peut finir
dans un lieu
des mauditions
par contre
c'est le même message
qui doit être prêché
pendant toute l'histoire
de l'humanité
pour plus réfratère
qu'il soit la société
donc l'évangile
de nos jours
appelé
l'évangile
du développement personnel
self-help gospel
est complètement
l'opposé
de l'essence
même de l'évangile
c'est l'évangile
sans la croix
donc la croix
elle est lieu
essentiel
efficace
pour manifester
ce qui nous sommes
dans notre pire
laideur
des corruptions
spirituelles
et en même temps
c'est les lieux
de notre plus grande
élévation
car nous sommes
crucifiés avec Christ
pour être ressuscités
avec lui
et donc
quelqu'un
qui a été
affranchi
par l'évangile
de Jésus Christ
a appris
à embrasser
!
l'escondade
de la croix
apôtre Paul
au contraire
de ces hommes-là
il n'est pas
en train de chercher
à se protéger
personnellement
ils veulent
ne pas être
persécutés
pour la croix
du Christ
et Paul
à l'opposé
les moments
où il a implanté
cette église
en Galatie
il a été
lapidé
il a été piétiné
à cause
de la croix
du Christ
donc un homme
de Dieu
c'est quelqu'un
qui est marqué
par les dons
de soi
par des renoncements
constants
il n'est pas en train
de faire usage
de l'église
afin de se protéger
il n'est pas en train
de changer
l'évangile
il n'est pas en train
de concilier
l'irréconciliable
séparé
l'inséparable
donc Paul
il n'était pas
préoccupé
à être agréable
selon la chair
il était
préoccupé
à être agréable
à Dieu
et donc
il était en train
de promouvoir
la vraie liberté
cette liberté
qui n'est pas
toujours dans la dépendance
que les pasteurs
dictent
comment on doit agir
à chaque circonstance
de la vie
c'est cette vraie liberté
qui n'est pas
en train de chercher
à nous motiver
à la sanctification
par les menaces
de perdre
notre salut
ni
par des
nouées
sans eau
comme le dit
Jude
présenter Dieu
comme un
esponseur
de nos
idolâtries
de nos idoles
de nos désirs
charnels
en fait
des sacrifices
chercher
à être
obéissant
pour que
la carrière
avance
pour que
l'argent
tombe
pour que
la vie
s'améliore
les christianistes
ne nous promet
jamais
une mer de rose
après la conversion
c'est un combat
Dieu ne nous donne
pas un pyjama
après la conversion
il nous donne
une armure
donc
une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement
dans la croix
promeut la liberté
par les dons
des soi
et c'est comme ça
qu'on doit vivre
si le christ
de la croix
est celui
qui m'a apporté
la vie
en souffrant
pour moi
c'est exactement
comme ça
que je dois
me retrouver
dans la manière
dont je vis
envers
mes semblables
est-ce que ma vie
est marquée
par cette réalité
est-ce que
les personnes
autour de nous
sont tentées
à utiliser un masque
à se comporter
d'une telle manière
ou est-ce qu'elles ont
la liberté
d'être
qui elles sont
vraiment en Christ
et qu'elles ont
la possibilité
de nous demander
de prier pour elles
de leur aider
dans un moment
de difficulté
le troisième point
celui d'aujourd'hui
c'est une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement
dans la croix
promeut
la sainteté
par une piété
sincère
plutôt qu'une religion
utilitaire
par une impiété
cachée
ça c'est vraiment
très étonnant
selon les langages
de l'apôtre Paul
car les circoncis
eux-mêmes
verset 13
ils ont ensemble
car les circoncis
eux-mêmes
n'observent
point la loi
mais ils veulent
que vous soyez
circoncis
pour se glorifier
dans votre chair
donc d'un côté
ils ont un agenda
où ils essayent
de se protéger
mais de l'autre côté
ils veulent
s'enrichir
aux expanses
des chrétiens
par contre
ils ont créé
un système
où
ils nous donnent
l'impression
qu'ils sont en train
d'accomplir la loi
parfaitement
car s'ils n'ont pas
cette position
d'autorité
ils ne peuvent pas
se rendre agréables
devant nos yeux
ils ne peuvent pas
nous manipuler
sauf que l'apôtre Paul
il connaissait
déjà
et déprimièrement
cette expérience
de vie
les circoncis
eux-mêmes
n'observent
point
la loi
donc
quel est
l'essence
quelle est la raison
d'être
de s'approcher
de la religion
certains d'entre nous
on a été à fond
dans nos péchés
sclaves de péché
et l'évangile
a fait
tous les sens
je me rappelle
très bien
qu'après ma conversion
j'ai eu des amis
qui quand ils ont
découvert
que j'étais
converti
m'ont invité
à venir
à leur église
et lorsque
je rentre
dans leur église
je me disais
il y a
très peu
de différence
entre
ma vie
dans les boîtes
des nuits avant
et ce que je trouve
dans cette église
et je me disais
ça fait pas
de sens
pour moi
Dieu
attire
les élus
par la beauté
de sa sainteté
l'épouse du Christ
l'église
ne va pas
attirer
les élus
les perdus
si on
change
ses habits
purs
modestes
sans
lampides
par des vêtements
très sensuels
afin d'attirer
les charnels
donc quel est
l'intérêt
de ces hommes
qui ne sont
point en train
d'accomplir
la loi
mais qui veulent
pénétrer
dans les églises
s'infiltrer
et nous donner
l'impression
comme s'ils étaient
en train
d'accomplir la loi
la seule réponse
c'est qu'ils veulent
s'y glorifier
dans votre chair
ils veulent
que les chrétiens
authentiques
mènent la même
vie hypocrite
qu'ils vivent
une vie
d'apparence
externe
mais des corruptions
internes
sépulcres
blanchis
c'est donc
une religiosité
utilitaire
par l'impiété
cachée
et c'est l'une des choses
les plus dangereuses
que nous voyons
dans les nominalismes
chrétiens
il suffit
qu'une église
baisse la garde
par rapport
à l'importance
de nous évaluer
personnellement
et de nous aider
à évaluer
mutuellement
l'authenticité
de notre conversion
il suffit
que la position
du pasteur
la visibilité
soit désirable
ou appréciable
par les bénéfices
et les conforts
temporels
et humains
qu'il puisse avoir
il suffit
que par exemple
nos séminaires
soient plus intéressés
à tenir
la roue
roulant
plutôt que
de se certifier
que chaque personne
qui veut
s'inscrire
au séminaire
soit vraiment
convertie
et surtout
vraiment
appelée
au ministère
qualifiée
pour le ministère
et nous voici
devant une dénomination
qui a pu grandir
de manière très légitime
au point de départ
mais qui à un moment donné
a gagné plus
d'influence politique
dans la société
devant l'état
qui a de l'influence
en termes
de faire
les royaumes avancés
et d'être persécuté
on connaît des
professeurs
ou des pasteurs
qui ne croient pas
à ce qu'ils disent
car parfois
ils peuvent
!
connaître
théoriquement
l'évangile
mais pas
être nés
de nouveau
et ils savent
que leur salaire
dépend
de ceux
qui disent
à l'église
il y a certains
qui dans l'académie
au séminaire
vont enseigner
ce qu'ils croient
vraiment
les libéralismes
théologiques
la bible
n'est pas
la parole
de Dieu
elle contient
la parole
de Dieu
mais ils disent
qu'à l'église
il faut qu'ils prêchent
l'orthodoxie
car sinon
ils vont perdre
!
leur emploi
l'opposé
est aussi vrai
parfois
la dénomination
est complètement
corrompue
mais les personnes
ne veulent pas partir
car elles ne veulent pas
perdre les privilèges
qu'elles ont dedans
des bâtiments
pour que l'église
se rassemble
des salaires
ils ne veulent pas
embrasser la croix
et donc
la religiosité
utilitaire
elle est minie
par une empiété
cachée
l'apôtre époil
ne perd pas du temps
pour nommer ces personnes
afin de ne pas leur donner
des plateformes
c'est la même chose ici
car les circoncis
c'est-à-dire
ceux qui sont
effectivement circoncis
avant il avait dit
tous ceux qui veulent
se rendre agréables
selon la chair
c'est-à-dire
de manière un peu plus large
apôtre époil
il est en train de dire
ça peut vous inclure là
car vous êtes
sous leur influence
ok
peut-être que vous voulez
les suivre
car vous voulez aussi
vous rendre agréable
selon la chair
participer à leur groupe
et maintenant
il n'est plus en train
de parler en termes
des potentiels
il est en train de parler
en termes des réalités
car les circoncis
et donc
il y a cette apparence
externe
des personnes
qu'on peut identifier
au sein de la communauté
les plus légalistes
entre nous
ceux qui s'habillent
d'une certaine manière
les plus exigeants
entre nous
en termes
des obéissances externes
!
c'est comme Luther
qui parlait
des écrits
des Erasmus
car parfois
dans l'apparence externe
dans la rhétorique
un non-chrétien
hypocrite
peut surmonter
les vrais chrétiens
dans l'apparence externe
car il vaut mieux
un chrétien authentique
qui se répand vraiment
lorsqu'il pêche
qu'un non-chrétien arrogant
qui est toujours
en train de donner
l'apparence
qu'il ne pêche pas
et donc Luther
il disait
Sterkus
in Argento Disco
c'est-à-dire
des excréments
sur un plateau
d'argent
car la rhétorique
des Erasmus
était super
il était très bien
avec la lettre
mais ce qu'il offrait
c'était
des excréments
Jésus
il a utilisé
les mots
très similaires
ces pucres
blanchis
rasté vipères
pourquoi vous
nettoyez l'extérieur
et l'intérieur
reste complètement
pourri
donc
ils ne peuvent
point accomplir
la loi
déjà
car c'est impossible
selon les descents
des dieux
qui à partir
du moment
où l'humanité
tombe dans les péchés
on est tous
radicalement
contaminés
par les péchés
et c'est impossible
d'accomplir
les moindres commandements
on a traversé
Saint Galate
c'est la thèse
de Paul
c'est très clair
car
ce que Dieu
exige de nous
en termes d'obéissance
doit engager
la totalité
de notre âme
de nos pensées
et de nos actions
donc il faut
en fait
derrière
chacun
des moindres commandements
il a ses commandements
il faut
non seulement
faire les choses
tout simplement
par devoir
ou faire tout simplement
l'apparence externe
du commandement
mais il faut
faire
toutes les choses
pour la gloire de Dieu
en aimant
c'est ça le résumé de la loi
aimer Dieu
de tout notre cœur
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
aimer Dieu
de toute notre pensée
de toute notre âme
de notre âme
et avec toutes nos forces
qui d'entre nous
a pu déjà
accomplir
les moindres commandements
de manière parfaite
aucun d'entre nous
ça veut dire
qu'à partir du moment
où j'essaye
d'obéir
les moindres commandements
je deviens
en essayant
de les faire
coupables
de ne pas
l'accomplir
comme il faut
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc tout
essaye
de plaire Dieu
tout simplement
sur la base
de mes efforts humains
ne peuvent
qu'aimer faire
encore plus
condamnable
devant les exigences
de Dieu
et pourquoi ?
est Dieu
injuste ?
au contraire
Dieu
il est tellement
digne
d'amour
il est tellement
beau
glorieux
que toute
obéissance
qui ne correspond
pas à la hauteur
de sa dignité
et de sa gloire
elle est déjà
condamnable
et donc
les circoncis
n'accomplit
point la loi
Jésus-Christ
lui-même dit
si votre justice
ne surmonte pas
celle des esprits
pharisiens
c'est fini pour vous
et donc
c'est impossible
par dessein
pourquoi
la loi
a été donnée
pour que Dieu
nous convente
davantage
que nous sommes
tellement
condamnables
tellement condamnés
la loi
elle ne fait
qu'éprovoquer
davantage
la désobéissance
si nous ne sommes
pas un Jésus-Christ
à cause
de notre nature
corrompue
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc
Paul
il est en train
de dire ça
clairement
c'est une question
théologique
la circoncision
tout comme
même les baptêmes
de soi-même
ou la centaine
ne peut opérer
aucune chose
si la foi
n'est pas là
on ne gagne pas
de superpuissance
en nous faisant circoncire
aucune personne
qui s'est fait circoncie
n'est passée
d'un moment à l'autre
à accomplir la loi
donc par des cents
la loi
nous a été donnée
pour approfondir
davantage
notre besoin
absolu
d'un substitut
quelqu'un
qui puisse
accomplir la loi
à notre place
que les fils
des dieux
viennent vivre
la vie d'amour
la vie belle
qu'on n'arrive pas
à vivre
par contre
c'est bien probable
que l'apôtre Paul
soit en train
de réprocher
les mêmes choses
que Christ
a réprochée
l'hypocrisie
guide d'aveugles
qui filtraient
les moucherons
et avalaient
les chemins
des personnes
qui lient
des fardeaux
pesants
et difficiles
à porter
et qui eux-mêmes
ne veulent pas
porter aucun fardeau
et encore plus
c'est très probable
que lorsque l'apôtre Paul
soit en train
de le dire
il n'accomplit
point la loi
c'est car
le plus probablement
il a été au courant
de certains scandales
cette personne-là
qui s'est présente
devant vous
qui prêche
avec une grande rhétorique
on a accès
à des informations
comme tous les scandales
qu'on voit
même dans les églises
évangéliques
dans les monastères
où
souvent
ceux qui sont
plus plongés
dans l'austérité
et dans l'apparence
externe
exagérée
des saintétés
sont les plus
corrompus
les plus promiscus
d'entre nous
les scandales
double vie
on a vécu
récemment
un cas
où la personne
s'est montrée
très préoccupée
car certains d'entre nous
écoutaient une musique
du monde
mais qui étaient
plongée
dans une vie
de prostitution
et donc
ces personnes-là
sont en train
de mener
une religiosité
utilitaire
à travers
une impiété
cachée
et quelle est
leur motivation
ils ne sont pas
intéressés à nous
intéressés à vous
ils sont là
surtout
afin
de prospérer
personnellement
donc là
il dit
mais ils veulent
que vous soyez
circoncis
pour se glorifier
dans votre chair
c'est clair
l'aspect littéral
est fou
car c'est
comme les histoires
d'Astérix
et Obélix
qui voulaient
ramasser
tous les
casques
c'est comme ça
que vous dites
ouais
pour
pour compter
leur gloire
voici
combien
combien des romans
on a détruit
et ces hommes
ils étaient dans cette dynamique
sauf qu'ils étaient
en train de
compter
la quantité
des prépulses
qu'ils étaient
en train de conquérir
pour se présenter
devant
cette agence
missionnaire
prosélytiste
comme certains
églises
d'entre nous
qui vont donner
plus ou moins
d'importance
aux personnes
par rapport
à la quantité
des membres
de leur église
et donc
l'intérêt
n'est pas
la vraie conversion
car c'est pas
si difficile
que ça
de remplir
un bâtiment
surtout
si on essaye
d'attirer
de manière
charnelle
des êtres
non convertis
on a été bien
avertis
contre des mouvements
qui parfois
sont très légitimes
des mouvements
d'implantation
d'église
qui vont mettre
beaucoup d'emphase
sur des aspects
humains
par rapport
à la décision
par exemple
on a déjà entendu
parler
qu'après 15 minutes
au sein d'une église
les personnes
peuvent décider
si elles vont revenir
ou non
sur la base
du confort
de l'excellence
etc
et moi je pense
à Jean Baptiste
qui était en train
de vivre
un vrai réveil
la hache
est déjà mise
à la racine
de l'arbre
tous ceux
qui ne présentent pas
les fruits
de répentance
seront lancés
à l'enfer
comment alléger
ces messages
et comment justifier
c'était pas
une église
belle
qui disait
les mercredis
du réveil
c'était l'évangile
pur
confrontatif
scandaleux
et les multitudes
sortaient des villes
pour aller
entendre les prédicateurs
et donc
certains mouvements
d'implantation
qui nous disent
des maîtres
dans notre vision
nous sommes
une église
qui dans
cinq ans
voulons
implanter
d'autres églises
pour Hachar
est venu vers nous
il nous a dit
c'est superbe
de vouloir
implanter
d'autres églises
c'est naturel
c'est biblique
ça doit être intentionnel
par contre
si
le coeur du pasteur
n'est pas
avec les brés
qui sont présentes
à cette église
il est en train
d'émener
une relation
utilitaire
avec cette église
Pierre
m'aimes-tu
va implanter
plusieurs églises
Pierre
m'aimes-tu
prends soin
de mes brés
de mon troupeau
paix
mon troupeau
par contre
si d'un côté
il y a
l'impiété cachée
de l'autre côté
il y a
une vie
qui promeut
la sainteté
par une piété
sincère
si ces manipulateurs
sont en train
de pratiquer
l'impiété
afin de promouvoir
leur propre vie
de l'autre côté
nous avons
l'autre archétype
l'apôtre-épaule
et qu'est-ce
qui caractérise
sa vie
donc déjà
une personne
qui a eu
l'expérience réelle
d'avoir été
écrasée
par la croix
du Christ
roman 7
je vous partage
ma compréhension
de passage
la description
de sa vie
à l'éminence
de sa conversion
désespérer
l'homme
que je suis
la loi
qui impose
sur moi
des exigences
qui
dès moi-même
je n'arrive pas
à accomplir
ma chair
est affaiblie
à cause de péché
et donc
l'apôtre Paul
ayant été
écrasé
par la loi
il voit
l'inefficacité
de sa circoncision
et de sa meilleure
éducation
en tant que juif
impossible
plaire Dieu
si je défends
de moi-même
plus loin
mes efforts
désespérer
l'homme
que je suis
complètement condamné
si je suis sincère
je ne vais pas
essayer
de faire semblant
que je suis en train
d'accomplir
la loi
et donc
l'apôtre Paul
au chapitre 2
il nous a dit ça
attention
car si j'ai rebâti
des choses
que j'ai détruites
qu'est-ce qu'il a détruit
c'était tous les systèmes
esclavagistes
de la loi
mosaïque
mal compris
par les juifs
je me constitue
moi-même
en transgresseur
ok
donc si vous voulez
après la conversion
revenir
à vous
mener votre relation
avec Dieu
sur la base
de Moïse
et pas sur la base
de Christ
à chaque fois
que vous transgressez
vous devez
présenter à nouveau
une perfection absolue
car
attention
c'est par la loi
que je suis mort
à la loi
afin de vivre
pour Dieu
vous comprenez
la compréhension
de la théologie
de Paul
par rapport
à la nouvelle naissance
c'est qu'à partir
du moment
où quelqu'un
est véritablement
mort à la croix
avec Christ
il est né
de nouveau
pour Dieu
la prédominance
et la progression
de sa vie
après la conversion
c'est
sanctification
donc c'est pas
la vie parfaite
pleine
que ça soit clair
mais c'est pas
une dispute
comme si on était
encore esclave
de la chair
la majorité
des textes publics
nous disent ça
très clair
y compris
Galate
lorsqu'il nous parle
qu'il influence
le Saint-Esprit
marcher dans l'esprit
et vous ne satisfairez
point
les désirs
de la chair
et donc il dit
!
je suis mort à la loi
à la fin des vies
pour Dieu
j'ai été crucifié
avec Christ
et si j'ai vie
ce n'est plus moi
qui vis
c'est Christ
qui vit en moi
et si j'ai vie
maintenant dans la chair
attention
j'ai vie dans la foi
du fils de Dieu
qui m'a aimé
et qui s'est livré
lui-même pour moi
je ne rejette pas
la grâce de Dieu
car si la justice
s'obtient par la loi
Christ est donc
mort en vent
quel est l'argument
de l'apôtre Paul ici?
c'est que si
nous avons été
humiliés
par la croix
du Christ
si nous avons été
humiliés par la loi
par l'impossibilité
d'accomplir la loi
nous sommes à la croix
morts avec Christ
pour notre vie passée
afin de vivre
avec Christ
pour une nouveauté
de vie
vivre pour Dieu
donc
les chrétiens
progressent
efficacement
sincèrement
et volontairement
en sanctification
indépendamment
de l'aspect
coercitif
de la loi
vous êtes avec moi
on n'est pas
motivé
par menace
ou récompense
il y a des motivations
à cet égard
en termes de discipline
ou grâce
les dieux
mais
la plus grande
motivation
de chrétiens
ne sont ni
les récompenses
ni les menaces
néo-brotiques
c'est véritablement
plaire
les cœurs
du père
et donc
les chrétiens
n'ont pas forcément
besoin des lois
afin d'accomplir
la loi
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc l'apôtre Paul
il n'était pas
en train de
se rendre
esclave
de tout un système
très lourd
afin de donner
l'apparence
de progresser
en santé
il était
un exemple
organique
humain
des piétés
la santé
dans la Bible
elle nous est présentée
comme une description
organique
et pas méthodique
ce ne sont pas
des règles
ou des méthodes
ou des calculs
qui nous conduiront
à la santé
c'est les fruits
de l'esprit
c'est mon intimité
avec Dieu
la prise de conscience
de ma nouvelle nature
ces influences
de son esprit
et à partir de là
je peux mettre
en marche
et progresser
en ressentant
cette vivification
qui vient
de la vigne
qui est Christ
et qui coule
en moi
les branches
donc la sanctification
elle est
organique
en Christ
et pas
méthodologique
par Moïse
et donc Paul
il a défendu ça
dans ses passages
c'est l'expérience
réelle
de tous les chrétiens
voilà pourquoi
les Galates
sans toute la lourdeur
des apparatus
mosaïques
ils mènaient
une vie plus sainte
que celui
qui avait
l'apparence externe
la plus sainte
d'entre les judaïsants
mais Paul
il était aussi
organique
par modèle
et ça c'est très important
car ça c'est une vérité
pour nous tous
comment voulons-nous
influencer
ceux qui sont autour
de nous
envers la sainteté
est-ce que c'est
par l'accusation
tout simplement
qui est par les réproches
ou surtout
par les modèles
voilà pourquoi
Paul
il était constamment
en train de dire
soyez mes imitateurs
et donc nous
nous devons
mener
une vie sainte
avec la certitude
que les modèles
qu'on portera
au sein de cette communauté
motivera les personnes
dans un encadrement
des grâces
la certitude
que nous sommes
véritablement
enfants des dieux
et emmenant
une vie d'enfant
en tant qu'enfant
avec similarité
avec les pères
donc la présence
de son esprit
c'est celle
qui produit
l'amour
porter les fardeaux
les uns des autres
aimez-vous
et vous allez
accomplir
la loi du Christ
et donc
dans un certain sens
les chrétiens
ne veulent pas
réjeter la loi
!
car en Christ
ça nous donne
des repères
et dans un autre sens
on n'a pas forcément
besoin de la loi
pour accomplir la loi
car accomplir la loi
c'est d'aimer
Dieu
et les prochains
nous
qui sommes parents
on fait
énormément d'efforts
des sacrifices
on sort
de la zone
du confort
on change
des couches
on fait
des sacrifices
on est généreux
on supporte
des mauvais comportements
parfois
on corrige
de façon dure
car on sait
que c'est le mieux
aussi
mais est-ce
qu'on aurait
besoin
des lois
pour les faire?
pas forcément
quand on prend
soin
de nos parents
âgés
c'est clair
que si nous sommes
sous l'influence
de l'hédonisme
de nos poises modernes
on peut être convaincu
ou nous laisser convaincre
plutôt
de manière assez cynique
que nous devrions prioriser
notre bien-être
qui est les biens
des personnes
qu'on aime
et qui nous aiment
une femme
organiquement
par nature
sans influence
diabolique
de notre génération
peut prendre
beaucoup de plaisir
dans les sacrifices
d'allaiter l'enfant
pendant toute la nuit
et les faire
de manière volontaire
avec tous les bénéfices
qui sont compris
par rapport
à l'enfant
on n'a pas besoin
parce que l'amour
est là
on n'a pas forcément
besoin des lois
et c'est l'illustration
qu'on puisse avoir
même si une poule
qui serait complètement
contre la nature
abandonne ses enfants
je ne vous abandonnerai
jamais
la vraie
conversion
c'est d'accomplir
effectivement
la loi
en Jésus Christ
progressivement
avec
un coeur
volontaire
car une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement
dans la croix
elle va promouvoir
la sainteté
à travers
une piété
sincère
on va promouvoir
la sainteté
en nous
et envers
ceux qui nous entourent
car la vraie piété
elle est
constamment
manifestée
par les modèles
qui nous sommes
en Jésus Christ
qui nous aident
par les modèles